da kann man alles tut mir ich hab mich
klar dass sie hier so auftrieb machen
und ich meine hier
auf dem rechten stuhl können sie platz
nehmen
ja immer ein kleines fernsehstudio mit
ja ja
nicht dass dieses
ja herr dr montgomery wie ist die lage
gut ich habe aber gehört was die
schweinegrippe betrifft die fälle
steigen gerade in den letzten tagen
dramatisch an ich glaube robert koch
institut hat am 19 11 30.000 gemeldet
gestern elfter elfter 50.000 wie geht es
weiter bezogen auf die schweinegrippe
ist die lage genauso wie vorhergesehen
man hat ja schon im mai als die erste
welle kamen gesagt es wird eine zweite
welle geben die ist jetzt da wir sind
gerüstet wir haben die chance für die
bevölkerung sich impfen zu lassen
ob der impfstoff jetzt gleich in
ausreichender menge zur verfügung stellt
das ist fraglich aber wer sich impfen
lassen will kann sich in den nächsten
wochen impfen lassen das ist die beste
voraussetzung um dieser attacke eines
virus sozusagen die spitze zu brechen es
ist die größte impfaktion in der
geschichte deutschlands so etwas hat es
noch nicht gegeben aber es ist ein
bisschen chaotischen sie nicht alle sind
sich einig es gibt ärzte die glaube ich
nicht impfen wollen die sagen der
impfstoff ist eigentlich zu stark dafür
weil dann gibt es ja auch diskussionen
was ist das zunehmen stoff da gibt es
ein verstärker drin der umstritten ist
und es gibt landstriche die nicht
versorgt sind es gibt zu wenig impfstoff
in teilen in köln gibt es jetzt glaube
ich
das ist ausgegangen jetzt muss man
wieder warten also hat man damit nicht
gerechnet oder wo ist wo liegen die
probleme also die probleme liegen darin
dass wir auch mit einer neuen situation
konfrontiert sind wir haben zum ersten
mal die chance bei einem völlig neuen
virus innerhalb der kurzen zeit die uns
das virus gelassenheit von wenigen
monaten eine total impfung der
bevölkerung durchzuführen wenn die
bevölkerung mit macht das ist etwas was
es in der weise nie gegeben hat das feld
auch ein bisschen er in den rahmen von
katastrophenschutz als von normaler
medizinischer versorgung deswegen haben
die länder sich auch dieser sache
angenommen und nicht die kassenärztliche
vereinigungen oder die ärzte sondern es
ist eine katastrophenschutz vorhaben der
länder und der bundesregierung man hat
zentral den impfstoff bestellt dieser
impfstoff kann naturgemäß nicht genauso
getestet sein wie die impfstoffe der
vergangenheit weil wir das virus hat
mike cannon deswegen hat man auf
europäischer ebene ein musterverfahren
entwickelt wie man einen impfstoff
zusammen mit den verstärkern getestet
hat an dem man dann lediglich die
eiweiße quenz des virus ausgetauscht hat
man lernte dass ein mockup in stickstoff
der iss getestet aber das argument der
endgültige impfstoff mit dem dann erst
seit mai bekannten h1n1 strang in der
antiken substanz der ist natürlich der
kann naturgemäß gar nicht getestet sein
und wieder sind der wissenschaft so ist
nun gibt es menschen die daraus darin
große probleme sehen die dann eine
wissenschaftliche debatte beginnen die
wir führen müssen bei der aber beim
nicht wissenschafts kundigen betrachter
natürlich dann eine unsicherheit zurück
bleibt und diese unsicherheit setzt sich
dann um in angst und diese angst setzt
sich um in impfmüdigkeit und das ist
eigentlich sehr schade und ich bin
sicher wenn wir in die details der
wissenschaftlichen argumente gehen wird
auch diese sendung am ende mehr zu einer
verunsicherung beitragen weil auch ich
kann ja nichts anderes sagen als dieser
impfstoff ist nicht an sehr vielen
menschen getestet sondern an weniger als
früher trotzdem habe ich mich impfen
lassen weil ich von dem konzept dieses
impfstoffes an sich überzeugt wir waren
bei ihnen die nebenwirkungen gar keine
ich habe die die einstichstelle
natürlich gespürt und sind männer heraus
spritzen an geht sowieso immer etwas
zurückhaltend und ich habe etwa einen
tag lang gemerkt dass da immer am
oberarm spritze gesetzt worden war ich
habe keinerlei nebenwirkungen verspürt
ich habe aber bei anderen kollegen
welche gesehen wir rechnen in etwa zehn
prozent der fälle von sogenannten
ordentlichen reaktionen also dass der
anblick wird dass es ein bisschen rot
wird das ist ein bisschen unangenehm ist
im muskel und erde vorbei einem prozent
auch durchaus allgemein symptome dass
man mal ein tag richtig mathe lich ist
dass es auch fieber gibt aber das sind
im grunde genommen wenn sie mich mal so
als arzt fragen sind das kleinigkeiten
gegenüber dem risiko an der
schweinegrippe wenn auch nur sehr selten
so doch zu sterben es gibt jetzt einen
bericht von einem kollegen der erzählt
er hatte herzrhythmusstörungen hat sich
impfen lassen hat fieber bekommen und
das sollte er eigentlich nicht bekommen
es war schlecht für sein herz wie ist
sowas zu bewerten ja wenn es von einem
kollegen im ärztlichen kollegen einst
war von einem journalistischen kollegen
also fieber und fieber sind zwei völlig
getrennte sachen wenn sie
herzrhythmusstörungen haben dann dürfen
sie kein fieber bekommen weil sie nicht
mit bakteriellen infektionen
konfrontierte und dieses fieber ist ja
nicht auf der basis einer bakteriellen
infektion da würde ich immer sagen
obwohl das vielleicht ihren juristischen
kollegen nicht beeindruckt da spielt
keine rolle hätte er das fieber durch
die schweinegrippe bekommen und dann
durch die schwächen bei der
schweinegrippe darauf aufgepflanzt eine
herzmuskelentzündung dann werden seine
rhythmusstörungen wahrscheinlich richtig
stimmen wollen gut es gibt ganz viele
argumente dafür und dagegen wo würden
sie denn sagen gibt es noch ein
restrisiko gibt es das gar nicht oder wo
sehen sie den knackpunkt bei dieser
impfung es gibt ein restrisiko wie bei
jeder eben schon auf der welt wissen sie
da wird immer von einer sehr seltenen
nervenerkrankung dem sogenannten
guillain-barré-syndrom berichtet wir
nennen das jetzt mal gps weil das ist
ganz einfach er muss man immer den
schwierigen namen sein dass eine
erkrankung die erstens sehr sehr sehr
selten das zweitens auch ohne impfungen
auftritt und drittens auch bei anderen
impfungen auftreten kann wer jetzt sagt
er lehnt die schweinegrippe impfung ab
weil er das risiko dass kilian barré
syndrom ist was bei etwa eins zu einer
million liegt für mich ausgetestet hält
der benutzt ein totschlagsargument gegen
jede form von impfungen die wir
überhaupt kennen das ist in meinem
nachteil nicht ganz sachlich und ich
glaube dass man mit solchen
totschlagargumenten als verstärker für
schwache eigene argumente nur versucht
die bevölkerung zu verunsichern
sie sind für die impfung was ist denn
für sie das wichtigste argument für
diese impfung das wichtigste argument
für die impfung ist dass wir durch die
schweinegrippe impfung bei einer
letalität von etwa 0,0 0 7% letalität
todesrate von einer einer sterberate
durch die infektion wenn man infiziert
ist von 0,007 prozent gleichwohl immer
noch für große teile der bevölkerung
infiziert werden davon ausgehen müssen
dass etwa 5000 menschen in der
bundesrepublik sterben ich als arzt sehe
die krisen chance das zu verhindern denn
an der impfung ist bisher noch niemand
gestorben das ist auch auszuschließen
sie können der medizin nicht
ausschließen ja das ist
das ist schon der ansatz zu glauben dass
wir in der medizin 100 ansatz des
ausschließend hätten ist falsch und
hiermit dass ich jetzt das was ich so
bedauere fördern wir natürlich wieder
die sorge aber wenn sie mal bedenken
dass bei 5000 toten im jahr das risiko
und 82 millionen bevölkerung in diesem
land das risiko im autoverkehr innerhalb
eines jahres zu sterben irgendwo in der
dimension von 1 250 tausend liegt und
deswegen menschen trotzdem bedenkenlos
auto fahren und wir ein risiko von eins
zu einer million eine nervenerkrankung
zu bekommen die übrigens dann auch
wieder reversibel unheilbar ist als
totschlag argument gegen die impfung
nehmen dann frage ich ob das noch sauber
und klar gedacht ist es geht um ein
abwägen das ist immer das geht immer um
ein abwägen von risiko und nutzen und
nach meiner einschätzung ist das risiko
dieser impfung kleiner und der nutzen
größer
es gibt jetzt nun auch europäische
behörden die das in anderen fällen ganz
anders sehen ich erinnere mich sie haben
ein iphone das ist ein paar mal in
frankreich geplatzt daraufhin sofort
eine kommissarin ja dann müssen wir es
vielleicht verbieten wenn das platzen
kann da kann sich ja einen finger
abzuschneiden
unter diesen umständen müsste man ja
auch den flugverkehr zum beispiel
verbieten man kann ja abstürzen ja dann
müssten sie ganz ganz furchtbar viel
verbieten hat man mit den impfstoffen
übrigens auch getan ich will ja nicht
verhehlen dass es auch länder gibt die
diesen impfstoff durchaus kritischer
sehen die schweiz zum beispiel hat den
impfstoff
lediglich für menschen zwischen 17 und
65 zugelassenen hat kleinere kinder
ältere menschen und schwangere frauen
ausgeschlossen von der verwendung an mit
pandemrix das muss man fairerweise
einfach sagen andererseits gibt es
länder wie zum beispiel belgien da ist
inzwischen die gesamte bevölkerung durch
geimpft ohne dass man eine einzige
nebenwirkung besonderer art bemerkt
hätte es gibt inzwischen ja in
deutschland in eine in europa muss man
sagen über eine millionen an wandte
pandemrix dosen und es gibt nicht eine
einzige berichtete uns erstaunen de
schwerwiegende komplikationen also man
kann es mit der mit der risiko
gläubigkeit der menschen auch
übertreiben und vor allem wird es immer
wieder bewusst genutzt und den menschen
angst zu machen warum was haben die
menschen die das nutzen für einen grund
da muss man sagen die haben auch gar
kein interesse daran oder gibts
interessen also teilweise gibt es einen
sich rennen in eine situation teilweise
gibt es das einfache interesse auf sich
und seine position aufmerksam zu machen
und damit auch
öffentlichkeit zu erreichen
dann gibt es einen grundkonflikt den ich
übrigens sogar nachvollziehen kann dass
viele dieser kritiker das ja verweben
mit einem geflecht von vorwürfen an die
pharmaindustrie die sich hier bereichert
was sie übrigens tut aber
das hilft uns alles nicht darüber hinweg
dass wir das virus jetzt hier habe man
etwas gegen das virus tun müssen und man
sollte jetzt wirklich den schutz der
bevölkerung im vordergrund stellen und
sich dann vielleicht nach dem mann
dieses virus bekämpft und besiegt hat
dann die frage stellen was können wir
besser machen dann stellen sie sich nur
mal vor dieses virus hätte die
gefährlichkeit des vogelgrippevirus
gehabt für dass diese planung ja mal
entwickelt worden ist würden wir heute
schon ganz andere dinge wir haben ja
glück dass wir an einem so relativ
harmlosen virus wie dem schweinegrippe
virus einmal unsere gesamte katastrophen
planung für den pandemiefall üben können
ich hoffe dass es uns gelingt ihr wissen
ja all diese argumente noch mal zu
sammeln sie auch alle noch sauber zu
erinnern dass vielleicht sich dann auch
alle noch an das erinnern was sie mal
gesagt haben um dann zu lernen wie wir
es das nächste mal besser machen können
da gibt es eine ganze menge was man
verbessern kann dann schließt sich
natürlich die frage wann ist denn diese
übung überhaupt nötig also ist es
überhaupt für so ne haben diese
erkrankung weil das ist ja dann das
gegenargument nötig diese große übung zu
machen also ich warne davor die
schweinegrippe in ihrer gefährlichkeit
jetzt ganz klein erstens bitte erinnern
sie sich daran was ihr für meldungen im
mai juni über die
weltgesundheitsorganisation aus mexiko
und dem amt den amerikas sag ich mal süd
und nord amerika bekommen haben damals
hatten wir alle richtig schiss dass das
eine sogar die so lange solche sarahs
weit über steigende gefährliche
erkrankung sei die da auf uns zukam und
die regierungen standen vor dem dilemma
dass sie im mai/juni sich entscheiden
mussten impfstoff zu kaufen der weltweit
limitiert war der war aus einem sehr
einfachen grund limitiert da muss man
jetzt einfach die abläufe der
impfstoffproduktion kennen der impfstoff
des jahres 2009 für die normale grippe
wird etwa zu beginn des jahres 2009
angesetzt in hühnereiern und braucht
dann drei bis vier monate um
präpariert zu sein und dann im august
letztlich fertig zu sein und vermischt
werden zu können diese
impfstoffproduktion war bereits begonnen
weltweit und konnte nicht unterbrochen
werden das heißt es ging darum wie viel
zusätzliche kapazitäten für die
herstellung neuer impfstoffe haben wir
und die pharmaindustrie ist limitiert
weltweit kann man nur 4,2 milliarden
dosen dieses impfstoffes herstellen und
die pharmaindustrie hat das getan was
man den wettbewerb system dann tut sie
an ihrer haut teuer zu markte getragen
und sie hatten mit den regierungen
gehandelt und die bundesregierung stand
etwa im mai/juni einfach vor der fast
erpresserischen aussage entweder er
unterschreibt jetzt einen vertrag und
kauft oder andere stehen da und sind
bereit zu kaufen und ihr könnt am ende
sehen was übrig bleibt so ist es einigen
staaten gegangen polen hat bis heute
nicht einen einzigen tropfen impfstoff
verkaufen können als land insgesamt die
müssen sich auf dem überschüssigen
pharmamarkt bedienen ich halte es für
richtig dass eine regierung angesichts
der dramatischen darstellung der lage
von mai juni versucht ihre bevölkerung
insgesamt zu schützen indem sie
impfstoff gekauft und wurde deswegen der
bundesregierung niemals ein vor allem
noch die alte muss man da zu sein einen
vorwurf machen dafür dass sie gehandelt
hat wie sie gehandelt hat trotzdem
langfristig müssen wir uns angucken ob
wir dieses kartell der pharmaindustrie
in diesem punkt nicht ein kleines
bisschen erträglicher für uns gestalten
drin kann denn diese dramatik der
situation wieder einsetzen ist diese
todesrate so festgelegt weil es sind ja
mal viel mehr gestorben an der
schweinegrippe eben mai juni ist dann
runter gegangen wurde und in den usa ist
die todesrate glaube ich 30 mal höher
als hier woran liegt das jeweils also
kann dass sich hier auch so
dramatisieren das kann sich theoretisch
und jetzt sind wir wieder im bereich
immer nur der spekulation kann sich das
ebenfalls auch noch hier bei uns
dramatischer wieder darstellt dafür sind
zwei gründe verantwortlich
der erste grund ist ein biologischer das
sogenannte resort man von den von den
400 muss man erklären
während wir uns mit h1n1 der
schweinegrippe auseinandersetzen sind
wir gleichzeitig täglich von ganz vielen
tausenden millionen aber millionen
anderer während bombardiert
mit denen wir lässig fertig werden
theoretisch aus der genetik von viren
ist es möglich dass in einer zelle sich
zwei wäre nämlich dass h1n1 auf der
anderen seite und irgendein anderes
virus plötzlich re kombinieren und einen
frankenstein virus entsteht etwas
anderes etwas neues das ist bekannt das
ist übrigens die genese aller neuen
virus strenge das ist theoretisch
denkbar und das ist die große sorge vor
allem der virologen gewesen die beim von
dieser berühmten hochzeit von vogel- und
schweinen da berichtet haben wenn sich
nämlich das vogelgrippevirus mit seiner
hohen tätlichkeit und das schweinegrippe
virus mit seiner hohen
ansteckungsfähigkeit wenn die beiden
sich getroffen hätten hätte in der tat
ein monster virus ein killervirus daraus
entstehen können das ist bis heute reine
theorie es ist denkbar aber noch nicht
erfolgt werden wir dagegen geimpft
auch dagegen muss man wiederum sagen die
chance dass wir dagegen geimpft ist
wieder im bereich der spekulation wenn
möglichst viel von dem h1n1 oberflächen
antigen mit bei dieser heirat übertragen
wird während wir dagegen immun wenn mehr
von dem anderen über käme wahrscheinlich
nicht mit allen zwischenstufen aber
trotzdem einfach über den kopf in den
sand stecken und gar nichts machen wäre
auch nicht gegangen noch mal der
vergleich jetzt zu amerika getroffen
haben die zweite frage wir wissen
offensichtlich dass es in den 70er
jahren bereits virus epidemie gegeben
hat die wir damals so gar nicht bemerkt
haben die wir auch vielleicht nicht zu
ernst genommen haben weil weder unsere
möglichkeiten der beobachtung der viren
noch unsere wahrnehmung der angehäuften
todesfälle so gut war noch die whu hier
weltumspannendes pandemie register hatte
und wir haben offensichtlich zumindest
in europa in den 70er jahren mit einem
ähnlichen h1n1 virus bereits kontakt
gehabt weswegen gerade die älteren
menschen in europa in einem hohen maße
immunität haben es sehr interessant dass
nur ein prozent der fälle in europa
älter als 60 sind während ganz viele
junge menschen von diesem virus
betroffen sind es gibt in europa
offensichtlich anders als in amerika
eine alte ich sage mal rest immunität
oder kreuzimmunität in der bevölkerung
gegen einer 1 inhaltslos das ist ja
spannend das ist so spannend weil wir
natürlich auch was risikogruppen angeht
die frage stellen müssen wir zuerst eben
finden müssen wird die über 60 wirklich
impfen müssen wir nicht vielmehr gerade
die jungen menschen biologisch ist das
ganze ein super krimi und ich bin sicher
darüber werden nur spannende bücher
schritt der kasus knaxus da hatten wir
vorhin drüber gesprochen ist ja der
wirkverstärker in dem impfstoff die
bundesregierung hat sich jetzt ohne
wirkverstärker impfen lassen für die
schwangeren soll auch ein anderer
impfstoff zur verfügung gestellt werden
warum werden diese unterschiede gemacht
wenn das doch so unproblematisch ist
naja es ist eben nicht so
unproblematisch
nehmen wir erst mal die frage warum hat
man einen wirkverstärker eben den
impfstoff für die gesamte bevölkerung
hineingetan
dieser wirkverstärker den hat man
deswegen ein getan weil man ursprünglich
die bereits wirkung des impfstoffes für
relativ niedrig eingestuft hat und
gesagt hat wir tun deswegen einen stoff
da rein was man an vielen anderen
impfungen auch macht das ist was völlig
normales also das nichts neues die
tatsache dass man im verstärker
wirkverstärker nimmt ist überhaupt
nichts neues der eine der beiden im
verstärker ist bereits 40 millionen mal
verwendet worden das 103 das ist jetzt
auch in dem 100 das ist dir der vz
reagieren dass es nicht in dem pandemrix
drinnen pandemrix ist mf 53 drin das ist
eine fortentwicklung die eben aber noch
nicht verwendet worden ist aber es ist
im grunde genommen beide stammen aus
einem stoff der squalen heißt und den
mann aus bestimmten eiweißen des
tintenfisches gewinnt im prinzip alles
bekannt in der kombination eben noch
nicht daraus saugen ja auch diese ganzen
verschwörungstheoretiker ihren honig und
versuchen deswegen die ganze impfung und
alles zu diskreditieren
also
h1n1 hat man für relativ
impfstoff hat man für relativ wenig
antigen gehalten deswegen den
wirkstoffverstärker mit rein getan um
einfach mit der halben dosis doppelt so
viele menschen zu erreichen so einfach
kann man es vielleicht formulieren das
heißt es braucht weniger wesen auch ich
brauche weniger weniger zucht wären
weniger satt wehren und kriegt mir
impfstoff und kriege mehr impfstoff nur
so waren wir überhaupt in der lage
innerhalb dieser produktionslinie für
deutschland auf 50 millionen dosen zu
kommen so nun kommt der fall mit dem
einzel impfstoff für die bundesregierung
dieser impfstoff unterscheidet sich
erheblich von allen anderen impfstoffen
die man sonst nicht durch den mangel an
wirkverstärker sondern durch die art wie
er entsteht bei den impfstoffen die
heute für die bevölkerung verwendet
werden
das ist ein so genannter spaltimpfstoff
da sie nur teile des virus nämlich die
virusoberfläche drin und alles andere
was übrigens zum teil auch krank machen
ist also bei der impfung krank machen
für die lokalen wirkung verantwortlich
ist hat man entfernt das ist eigentlich
eine kluge eine vernünftige der
impfstoff der bundesregierung hat keinen
verstärker enthält dafür aber den ganzen
das ganze virus das ist ein ganz im
stoff im gegensatz eben wie gesagt so
bearbeitete sie ihren hier
selbstverständlich abgetötet und bei
jedem schwein gekauft
sie sind abgetötete ganze viren im
gegensatz zu abgetöteten spalt teilen
der viren hier wirkt wenn sie so wollen
der rest des virus wie ein natürlicher
impfverstärker
dieses konzept was bei baxter c warmen
verwendet wird geht im kern auf die uhr
entwicklung der grippe impfstoffe in den
40er und 50er jahren des vergangenen
jahrhunderts zurück
zu behaupten dieser impfstoff sei besser
und der andere so schlecht ist
fahrlässig weil das kann man so nicht
sagen sie haben unterschiedliche
prinzipien
und es gibt kein besser und kein
schlechter es gibt allerdings vielleicht
unterschiede in der frage wie viele
menschen durch den impfstoff auch
wirklich immun werden denn das ist
übrigens auch noch ein irrtum der in der
bevölkerung herrscht nicht hundert
prozent aller menschen geimpft werden
entwickeln dadurch auch immunität
die zahl liegt bei pandemrix und bei ein
paar momentan irgendwo zwischen 70 und
80 prozent
das ist aber schon hoch das ist sehr
viel und dass es vernünftig deswegen
diese im stoffe zu verwenden aber warum
hat die bundesregierung weil es ist ja
eigentlich was die öffentlichkeitsarbeit
betrifft ein desaster einen anderen
impfstoff für sich bestellen lassen als
für die bevölkerung die erklärung der
bundesregierung die ich nicht nachprüfen
kann sondern nur glauben muss ist das
ein ganz alter liefervertrag ist der
schon seit jahrzehnten bestünde dass die
bundesbeamten immer mit einer impfstoff
der firma baxter gegen grippe geimpft
werden und da das mit dem pandemrix
überhaupt nichts zu tun habe mit der
pandemieplanung überhaupt nichts zu tun
haben ich kann das nicht überprüfen ich
muss das glauben okay gut ich habe hier
noch eine wunderbare
verschwörungstheorie die ich unbedingt
anbringen möchte und zwar geht eine mail
durchs internet die sagt die adjuvantien
also dieser verstärker im pandemrix was
eben hier in deutschland fast
ausschließlich eingesetzt wird lösen das
golfkriegssyndrom aus mit chronischer
müdigkeit und muskel räume die these
wird daher geleitet weil auch die
soldaten im ersten golfkrieg mit einem
ähnlichen mitteln dem worden sind und
die jetzt so an großen teil an dem
golfkriegssyndrom leiden was sagen sie
dazu gar nichts
man muss nicht auf jeden unsinn etwas
anderes drauf setzen wissen sie dieser
monokausale betrachtungsweise angesichts
dieser armen menschen die im golfkrieg
kämpfen mussten die gift waffen
ausgesetzt worden die den den dänischen
dieser brennende öl quellen ausgesetzt
worden die in extremen klimatischen
verhältnissen unter extrem schwierigen
ernährungs und trinkt bedingungen
arbeiten mussten nun alles monokausal
auf diesen einen impfstoffverstärker
zurückzuführen das sind einfach wäre
wissenschaftliche ideen hier bitte ich
einfach irgendwann mal mit ein bisschen
ruhe und ratio den beweis anzutreten und
nicht einfach irgendwas ins netz zu
stellen was nur die leute schon sichern
soll es gibt ja auch die meinung es wird
eigentlich viel zu sehr übertrieben mit
der schweinegrippe die normale grippe
wäre eigentlich viel gefährlicher da
müssten jeden tag dutzende tote gemeldet
werden stimmt das ist die normale also
die üblichen grippe erreger sind die
viel gefährlicher als die schweinegrippe
ja das ist so wir haben zurzeit eine
lage wo wir in den letzten jahren
pro winterhalbjahr zwischen 8 und 11
tausend menschen
feststellen mussten die an den folgen
der grippe der klassischen alten
wintergrippe oder saisonalen grippe wie
wir sie nicht gestorben sind das sind
etwa übrigens im winterhalbjahr zwischen
60 und 100 am tag
ich sag es mal sehr einfach da hat kein
hahn danach gekräht
weil wir haben die grippe impfung
angeboten man muss immer dazu sagen die
meisten dieser menschen
sterben ja nicht an der grippe alleine
sondern die sind chronisch krank die
sind zum teil auch sehr betagt und dann
kommt eine grippe und jetzt sag ich mal
unendlich gibt ihnen den rest
das ist wahr das ist richtig das wird
auch dieses jahr so sein mit einer
einschränkung auf die ich gleich noch
eingehe trotzdem ist das argument auch
hoch zynisch wir haben die chance mit
einer impfung 5000 menschen vor dem
sterben zu bewahren egal ob sie
vielleicht etwas anderen stärken würden
und ich kann doch jetzt nicht mehr den
zynischen argument dass viel mehr an der
anderen gemischt haben jetzt sagen
deswegen lasse ich die schweinegrippe
impfung seien halte die schweinegrippe
schon haus tierchen und die normale
grippe von raubtieren
das ist schlicht wissenschaftlich
blödsinn das ist nicht weit genug
gedacht und deswegen kann ich dieses
argument nicht akzeptieren jetzt gibt es
aber einen zweiten effekt und ich komme
zurück auf die momentane beobachtung bei
der wintergrippe wir stellen fest dass
in diesem jahr bisher die infektion mit
der wintergrippe offensichtlich sehr
viel
zahlenmäßig geringer sind als in den
vergangenen jahren zu erwarten hier
findet ein konkurrenz effekt
offensichtlich stadt zwischen dem h1n1
virus und den normalen grippe viren und
interessanterweise
überwiegt das h1n1 derartig dass die
andere virus populationen sich in den
geschwächten menschen gar nicht
ausbreiten kann weil die erstmal mit
h1n1 kämpfen am ende kann dabei
herauskommen dass dieses jahr mit der
h1n1 epidemie insgesamt weniger menschen
sterben als wenn wir die normale
originäre wintergrippe die wir jedes
jahr erleben hier hätten über das land
gehen sehen durch den verdrängungseffekt
von h1n1 und klassischen hinter
grippeviren
hochinteressant ist als erster theorie
bei dem ersten treffen der impfstoff
experten der whu am 27 oktober in genf
diskutiert worden und alle virologen
achten zurzeit und guckt momentan darauf
was sich daraus entwickelt das heißt der
schweinegrippe virus ist bezüglich
seiner vermehrung ein äußerst
aggressiver virus weil er alles andere
verdrängt
h1n1 die schweinegrippe ist deswegen ja
auch so hoch ansteckend ein mensch der
in der u-bahn ordentlich hustet und
schöpft kann hundert andere anstecken
und deswegen gibt es übrigens über die
individuelle risiko nutzen abwägung
jedes bürgers ob er sich impfen lassen
wählen die man ihm nicht ersparen kann
und die auch legitim ist es ist auch
legitim wenn jemand sagt ich will mich
nicht impfen lassen weil ich nunmehr
angst habe davor wir haben in
deutschland keine im 3 deswegen gibt es
darüber hinaus aber auch noch eine
bevölkerungs medizinische abwägung weil
nämlich jeder der das virus in
sicherheit zwei tage schon bevor er
überhaupt merkt dass das hat und krank
wird bereits andere menschen anstecken
kann und wenn nur jeder der es hat 100
andere ansteckt haben wir in kürzester
zeit eine explosionsartige vermehrung
des virus das ist hochansteckend hoch
kontaktlos deswegen auch in meinen augen
die völlig selbstverständliche forderung
dass sich medizinisches personal vor
allem diejenigen die mit
immungeschwächten patienten umgehen
impfen lassen sollte um nicht selber zur
quelle des virus für andere kranke
menschen zu sein die wesentlich
schlechter damit umgehen könnten als wir
die gesunde kräftig sind das heißt auch
ein wichtiges argument von ihnen jeder
geimpfte bildet quasi eine schutzmauer
um die ungeimpften weil er den virus
nicht mehr weiter geklebt dafür in der
in der enz technik ein wunderbares
französisches ort in cordon sanitaire
wenn es uns gelingt diesen cordon
sanitaire durch viele geimpfte menschen
rund um das virus zu legen kommt es
nicht raus in die großen teile der
bevölkerung und das gelänge dann
wirklich eine viruserkrankung
auszurotten ist das frei übersetzt so
etwas wie die mauer der hygiene oder
kann man so sagen eine hygiene mauer
durch viele geimpfte das virus prallt
sozusagen in jedem individuum an die
mauer der antikörper und kann nicht sie
ist eine krankmachende wirkung entfalten
eine frage gibt es noch die immer wieder
oft auftritt was generell impfungen und
eben speziell diese dann auch als
massenimpfung betrifft das ist eine
überreaktion des immunsystems direkt
nach der impfung die dazu führen kann
dass man tut umgibt den anaphylaktischen
jenna also kreislaufzusammenbruch und
der kann bis zum tod führen wie hoch ist
dieses risiko in dem zusammenhang
einzuschätzen das kann ich ihnen jetzt
nicht in zahlen liefern weil die habe
ich jetzt spricht man nicht präsent das
risiko ist nicht nur bei impfungen das
ist bei jeder applikation eines bei
jeder anwendung eines eigentlich
allergenen stoffe bekannt dass ist
kennen alle aus der westen stich
allergie wonach ein wespenstich
theoretisch tot umfallen kann diesen
anderen praktischen shop kann es immer
geben wenn man in den körper etwas
einbringt was eine starke antigene
wirkung hat kann auch bei impfungen
seien ich weiß gar nicht ob das dann auf
den verstärker oder auf das
auf die virus bestandteilen selber ist
das ist eines der ganz typischen risiken
der impfung
deswegen darf man die impfung eben auch
nicht sage ich mal vom pförtner am
eingang einer versicherung machen lassen
sondern sie muss von ärzten vorgenommen
werden und weil diese reaktion sofort
auf und ärzte bis nach entsprechend
ausgebildet sein um sie sofort behandeln
zu können wenn ein ausgebildeter arzt
sofort eine andere praktische reaktion
behandelt wenn er die entsprechenden
medikamente zur verfügung hat die man
braucht niemand in einer arztpraxis
aufgezogen fix und fertig wir haben sie
bei uns in der klinik an der wand kleben
mit plastikstreifen wieder abzureißen
diese werden täglich erneuert diese
diese spritzen wenn das gegeben ist ist
das eine beherrschbare situation und
dann und jetzt sind wir wieder bei den
100 prozent einsatz aber dann dürfte
eigentlich niemand damit dauerhaft zu
schaden kommen 1 habe ich aber auch
quecksilber soll drin sein eine
quecksilberverbindung und da wird dann
gefragt muss das denn sein quecksilber
sein schweres nervengift muss das denn
sein dass das ausgerechnet ich das beim
arzt verabreicht bekommen auch hier muss
mal wieder die mengen debatte
vergleichen damit es ist in der tat
richtig dort ist ein konservierungsstoff
sprinter hat die mehrzahl der muster
drin sein weil die bundesregierung in
ihrer unendlichen weisheit den impfstoff
in zehner packungen gekauft hat das
heißt da sind immer zehn portionen in
einer ampulle da sie die nicht einmal
rausziehen spritzen und wegwerfen
verwenden können sondern über einen tag
halten müssen muss ein
konservierungsstoff drin sein der heißt
thiomersal und enthält quecksilber
quecksilber in
absolut dramatisch geringen
dimension wer regelmäßig ein- bis
zweimal in der woche seefisch ist nimmt
etwa dieselbe menge quecksilber auf in
der woche wie mit einer impfung mit
diesem stoff trotzdem es ist eine
zulässige debatte ist richtig dass
darüber diskutiert wird andere
impfstoffe enthalten das thema mehr sei
nicht und wenn sie wenn man vom rathaus
kommt ist man klüger heute wird die
bundesregierung nicht mehr zehn päckchen
mit thiomersal bestellen wir lernen
daraus und dennoch ist das kein argument
gegen die impfung also ihre
zusammenfassung es gibt risiken die sind
aber deutlich geringer als die risiken
der schweinegrippe ist es richtig
zusammen absolut es gibt risiken bei
dieser impfung wie bei allen anderen
impfungen auch diese risiken sind
deutlich geringer als bei der
schweinegrippe
dass es risiken gibt können sie alleine
daran sehen dass sämtliche bundesländer
inzwischen in ihre gesetze diese impfung
gegen h1n1 mit aufgenommen haben was
übrigens bedeutet dass nach der
rechtsordnung der bundesrepublik einen
in staden 1 wie eine anerkannte
berufskrankheit die eine anerkannte im
krankheit dann automatisch auch aus
staatlichen stellen reguliert wird und
auch die schadensersatzleistungen und
auch die folgekosten vom staat getragen
werden also auch noch mal ein
finanzieller vorteil der impfung die
schweinegrippe ist nicht ich habe die
impfung ist versichert ja das wäre
allerdings sehr traurig wenn man sagen
würde der schaden ist versichert
deswegen sollen die leute hingehen und
die schweiz ich sage mal zuallererst
gehen wir davon aus dass die impfschäden
nicht so sein werden wie sie von manchen
menschen beschichtet und dargestellt
werden die im staaten debatte um die
normale grippeimpfung hat es ja auch
schon seit jahren nicht mehr gegeben
weil ganz offensichtlich diesen
impfgegnern die argumente ausgegangen
sind okay vielen dank